i'ma cartilage been the acting returning
officer for the Berlin constituency do
hereby give notice that the number of
words recorded for each candidate is as
follows bird whistle garden Liberal
Democrats 6046 commies Tom UK
Independence Party
2472 Cooper Julie Elizabeth Labour Party
18,000 832 miss Laura
the Green Party 461 white Paul the
Conservative Party twelve thousand four
hundred and seventy nine
[Applause]
there were 63 rejected ballot papers and
the turnout was 62.3%
and I do hereby declare that Julie
Lizabeth Cooper is duly elected
[Applause]
oh thank you I would like to begin by
thanking the returning officer for his
work tonight and I'd also like to pay a
tribute to the saffron Burnley Council
know everyone
it was helped make this such an
efficient count tonight and for the good
careers visit carried it out we were all
very I'm sure all the candidates are
grateful for that and thank you very
much who knows maybe next year we'll be
rivaling Newcastle here but it really it
has been very efficiently rolling are
unimpressed and I'm sure you all are
this has been an election fought against
probably an unprecedented situation when
the country sounds art across walls
following our decision to leave the
European Union and against a background
of some of the most horrific terrorist
attacks that this country's ever seen
we've had an election that's been halted
on two occasions by these attacks with
campaigns I rarely come to a standstill
and there are those out there who are
many from seek to dividers and to to
foster hatred amongst communities
intersect one community against another
and I'm delighted tonight and extremely
grateful to the people of Burnley and
Padian who have locked me on these
issues who have looked at manifestos who
have looked at ideas and a sort of
choose hole over here trading division
and pleased that they've looked at the
labor manifesto and they've seen that we
offer a fair and decent way forward for
this country as it is an absolute honor
and privilege to represent them the
Imperium in Westminster I've enjoyed the
task I sometimes been challenging always
hard work for
two years and I look forward to honoring
all the commitments that I've made
people on thousands of doorsteps
throughout this very short campaign the
people I'm proud of people in Burnley
and podium they they're chose a decent
fair way forward thank you very much